Passons plutôt par là.
Attends attends...!
Quoi ? Tu as senti une perturbation dans la Force ?
C'est vrai qu'on peut pas pécho ?
Quoi ?
Dans le Code Jedi, y'a rien qui dit vraiment qu'on n'a pas le droit de pécho...?
Un Jedi ne doit pas se laisser guider par ses émotions.
Ok ?
– Ok.
– Ok !
Eeeeeet... pour la nique ?
Il n'y a pas d'émotions, il n'y a que la peine !
– C'est clair ?
– Nan.
On reparlera de ça en temps voulu ; en attendant, concentrons-nous sur notre mission.
Mais admettons euh... qu'une Jedi,
en pleine vigueur de la jeunesse, tombe sur un Twi'lek beau gosse, derrière l'Académie et que...
ben une chose en entraînant une autre...
elle lui aurait un peu... roulé des pelles.
T'as roulé des pelles à Terek ?
Non...!
Bon, ben j'imagine que si t'as juste roulé des pelles c'est pas si grave.
Quoi t'as fait plus que ça ?
– Je n'ai pas branlé une teub...
– T'as branlé une...!
Et du coup t'es pas passée du Côté Obscur ?
– Ben non, j'crois pas.
– Pourtant l'émotion, la passion, l'agitation
sont des voies qui mènent au Côté Obscur.
Non pas forcément, regarde Mace Windu !
Maître Windu est un Jedi exemplaire, il maîtrise parfaitement ses émotions !
Pff ! Tu vas pas me faire croire qu'il chope pas des meufs, Mace Windu.
Il a un sabre violet, c'est forcément un lover.
On y est.
Couvre-moi.
Et un rêve érotique, ça compte ?
Je sais pas, oui ! Sûrement, oui !
– Mais si on se fait doigter ?
– Quoi ?!
Nan mais dans un rêve !
QUOI ?!
Oh ça va !
T'as jamais été attiré par personne, toi...?
Non ? Jamais...?
Arrête, tu m'perturbes la Force avec tes questions !
T'es à ça de passer du Côté Obscur
On parle de moi ?
J'essaye de pas m'abandonner à la colère mais c'est chaud, là !
T'inquiète, j'suis là.
J'veux pas mourir puceau !
En vous abandonnant au Côté Obscur, vous pourriez goûter à tous les plaisirs...
Plus rien ne vous serait interdit !
Plus...
Plus rien ?
Laissez-vous envahir...
par vos désirs les plus secrets...
Et on a le droit avec des Ewoks ?
Des Ewoks ?
Mais attendez mais c'est dégueulasse, les Ewo...
Ça va ?
T'as essayé d'me pécho, là !
T'as essayé d'me pécho !
Je n'ai pas essayé de te pécho.
Oh, dégueu'...!